Johnson recibe otro duro golpea a su
debilitada carrera política este 15 de
junio el comité de privilegios del
parlamento concluyó que mintió
deliberadamente durante la investigación
del partygate el escándalo de las
fiestas en la residencia oficial de Down
Street cuando Reino Unido se encontraba
en estricto confinamiento por la
pandemia del covid 19
mintió mintió los parlamentarios mintió
a la gente de este país le mintió a las
enfermeras a los médicos a los
cuidadores a los conductores de autobús
a todos los que estaban poniendo en
riesgo su vida durante la pandemia
un documento de más de 100 páginas
emitido por la cámara de los comunes
reveló que Johnson estuvo suspendido
durante 90 días antes de que renunciara
a su cargo como diputado conservador el
pasado 9 de junio
el reporte de talla 6 eventos realizados
en las oficinas y en su residencia de
las cuales él tenía conocimiento
Johnson quien estuvo frente al gobierno
entre 2019 y 2022 y renunció por este
escándalo habría sido cómplice de una
campaña de abuso e intento de
intimidación al comité investigador
según el informe el cual fue tildado
como basura por el ex Primer Ministro
creo que el informe es bastante
condenatorio es serio Boris Johnson no
solo es un infractor de la ley sino
también un mentiroso no es apto para un
cargo público se ha deshonrado a sí
mismo y continúa actuando como tal es
como Trump en la forma en que trata de
desacreditar a cualquiera que critique
sus acciones con este último episodio se
hace más evidente el debilitamiento
político de Johnson y la división dentro
del partido conservador la cual podría
aumentar la presión sobre el actual
Primer Ministro Richie sunak en su
intento por impulsar la economía
británica y para la cual necesita el
apoyo parlamentario